what your mom got him alright with it
until was it the piercing that finally
she said that ridiculous of all the
things I did when I cut my nose bears
she was like you know I just I just
don't understand why you had to get your
nose pierced this is mom really I'm
naked I'm like every magazine I fit
naked since the beginning yes my mama
yeah I've had my ass out since 2007 let
me show this is you out at giy nightclub
were you getting your ass out oh yeah I
just love the deaths Jeremy I don't who
that is I look at their eye line because
I had it waxed they're in a state of
horror I mean I'm the Venus the Venus
wouldn't be waxed the Venus would feel
free it should be proud to be a woman
who cares
okay were you channeling the god of love
when you had this picture taken essence
that's amazing do you think I don't
never seen thus far it's beautiful I may
put that on my posters I personally
think I look like a dropped rifle
my two nieces this weekend just gone and
they are am 6 years old and 2 years old
and the first things they both said to
me before hello the first niece went
uncle Greg we're not allowed to talk
about your fat tummy anymore meat and
the 3 year old when you are fat
after the best pure honesty
I've gotten
my sister let's show some clean bits of
when I'm on TV shows and I've got a joke
but I do that freaks them out can I do
it yeah which camera my on that one
there yeah
Lucy Daisy I'm stuck in Italia go
it makes the makes the younger one cry
who's fat now
are you a fan of Kim and Kanye or do you
hate them
no I love work I mean Kim Kardashian has
you know her I'm she's a nice person
when you been around you that dancing
you setting me is how big that tattoo it
have you added to it is that the same
size it is from mid-back
all the way down what it look oh there
it is again